pedro pascal introduced his sister to
the world on tuesday
the same day she publicly came out as a
transgender woman the mandalorian star
sweetly supported his sister lux by
posting a photo of the cover for a
spanish language magazine
writing which translates to my sister
my heart our lucks luxu is 28 and is now
studying
acting at juilliard in new york made
sure to share the messages of support
her brother gave her
saying pascal has been an important part
of this he's also an artist
and has served as a guide for me he was
one of the first people to gift me the
tools that started shaping my identity
lux also shared pascal's reaction when
she came out to him
over facetime saying her brother asked
me how i felt because i remember he was
a little worried
but after hearing that lux was happy he
quickly congratulated her
saying perfect this is incredible
in the future lux revealed that she had
started hormone treatment
back in july and she had previously come
out to her family as non-binary my
transition has been something that's
very natural for everyone
in my family it's almost something that
they expected to happen
we need trans activists who are good
smart informed and who can be strong
voices
against transphobia homophobia and
racism
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos